welcome
everybody to the gazebo zone
join me under the gazebo would you
please
guys welcome to the gazebo zone i need
you guys
to understand okay that when i express
anything here under the gazebo it's
correct and true and all opinions given
forth are infallible are are
indisputable and by the very nature of
themselves
impossible to contradict that is what it
means to be under the gazebo and i thank
you all for joining me
here today in the correct opinion zone
thank you to our sponsors quip
stitch fix and dollar shave club if you
would like to share your opinion under
the gazebo with us today give us a call
at 808 hot meme
give us a ring today we'd love to hear
from you
how are you good um there was an episode
of the prophet
where he helped a business of people who
were making
gazebos that's funny and every time they
said gazebo i had to giggle it's like i
can't
but it's so weird all of a sudden
everybody's talking about gazebos
like once when did you ever hear gazebo
used in a conversation
ever i can't hear it without laughing
now though they
literally made gazebos that was their
company yeah
um they were in the gazebo zone
yeah they were nice gazebos they were
not your everyday uh
tlc gazebo let me tell you these were
premium made
guys welcome everybody thank you for
joining us so
wonderful to have you here i'm here
joined by the illustrious beautiful
eli cline my my pregnant beautiful wife
by the way i say pregnant beautiful wife
because ever since
that we found out you're pregnant and
we're always like all right you're still
pregnant because you
because it's like kind of uneasy during
the first three months because
you can have a miscarriage somewhat
commonly like 10 to 15
i read but i just i think it's so
amazing
you're so cool i always think that to
myself
they say apparently there's already a
heartbeat
that's unbelievable oh where it is and
they say
well this was we read they described the
baby that she has
as the size of a pip an orange seed
an orange seed but they called it a pip
which i thought was really funny a pip
squeak
a little pip but i just think it's so
amazing that eliz
has this little pip inside of her i
don't know i just
i'm so charmed by that i just think it's
amazing
and you've gained a little weight you've
been eating great she's super healthy
she's
radiant i'm already gaining weight let's
see how much
look at this i just i'm i'm so in love
with my beautiful pregnant wife
who's got this little pip inside of her
we've got our first ultrasound in like
uh two weeks
a week a week oh shh right
yeah i think it's two weeks i can't
believe it
it still feels so surreal but yeah
that's gonna make it feel real
yeah yeah sure there's your little pip
we're trying to think of a name maybe
pip
ela hates now go with your first
instinct pen for sure
just go for it at any rate guys let's
get into the show
i'm charmed to be here you're let's get
started right away with your goof of the
day there's a lot to get to
um under the gazebo here today
now this video comes courtesy of your
boy tom segura i saw this on his
instagram
and i had to share it with you
so this is a professional boxer who is
having
promoting a big fight he's having and um
this i'm trying to break this down for
you guys because it's so
it's so wild okay let me show you the
video so he's on a daytime television
show and some
mascot comes out dressed in a burrito
and um i think he was meant to punch him
in the stomach because you can see the
house being like
hit him right here hit him right here
and this box this is a boxer
a world-class fighter he punches this
[ __ ] guy in the
face as hard as he can dude and you
could tell
that burrito that tortilla padding just
isn't enough
so let's see who's usually inside those
two it's probably
not like a guy not someone who can take
a punch
so apparently something flew off
and so apparently he broke this poor son
of bitch's jaw and you see him writhing
around in pain and everyone's kind of
clowning on him
but he you see he's like trying to like
yeah
he's like dude i'm not okay and
everyone's clowning on him
he goes right in the stomach in the
[ __ ] phase
he does pat the stomach and then last
minute yeah
i think it's his fault really the host
well i don't know if anyone speaks
spanish maybe he was like punch him here
definitely don't punch him maybe
he just decked that poor guy he probably
had like padding like extra padding in
the stomach
yeah and nothing in there oh
so apparently he broke his jaw and this
guy said on twitter
i don't know it sounds ironic his
apology because it kind of gave me a
good goal he said
i sincerely apologize to the brave man
that was injured
i have the utmost respect for him his
part he's talking about the guy in the
burrito suit
i have the utmost respect for the
burrito boy
uh his participation willingness and
courage he says
true hero if this is true i would
personally like to invite him to my
december first fight are you
trying to give this guy flashbacks does
he have to wear his burrito costume
i don't know why i just it had me uh in
stitches frankly
uh he he tossed the he he beat the salsa
right out of the burrito
not a mexican joke a burrito joke let's
be clear i've gotten way more classic
integrity you can make race
related jokes about because they put
salsa in burritos
as well as rice and beans and stuff like
that i thought that was clear
do i need to make an apology
[Laughter]
um here's another good one
shannon your pizzas here okay
this is just a goofy we're just getting
started here we're lubing it up we're
lighting it up you know what i'm saying
so this person decided to order a pizza
and they put a sign on the door that
said scream
shannon your pizza is here do not ring
the doorbell or knock
our grandma is sleeping upstairs you
know i have to say
what do you think about somebody leaving
a sign on a door for pizza delivery guy
to scream shannon your pizzas here no
one would actually do that
yeah it's a kind of it's asking a lot of
a pizza guy scream
most people will probably not even read
the letter
i'm not about asking someone to scream
like i'm not
screaming yeah you know what i mean but
this guy
he he receives the note
and he reciprocates so what did the note
say again it said
scream please scream shannon your pizzas
here because my grandma is sleeping and
the doorbell will wake my nan up
so let's see how this uh brilliant mind
reacts to that
and look at this guy strutting up like a
thousand pizza like
this guy's a pizza god if i've ever seen
one he assesses the situation
he strolls up with the confidence of a
thousand fupas a thousand pies
i feel like there's no sound yeah
there's no sound oh well that's pretty
critical
do you have oh yeah i got it i fix it oh
let's try it again there we go there we
go
so foopish maximus approaches the door
with pizza in hand
the cru the crows are calling in
anticipation
of what's to come
and then she opens the door and screams
in her face too
now what i'm wondering is because asking
a pizza boy to shout
i wonder if this was his way of being
like [ __ ] you for making me shout it's a
little bit of rebellion
yeah malicious compliance well first of
all you know nana
woke the [ __ ] up from there you know
what i mean and second of all she opens
the door and he continues
to scream in her face so you know what i
mean
it's just so weird like i wonder if it
was a revenge because who
this guy really sees the opportunity
you know i love that the crows are
crying
i don't think i've ever screamed like
that
it's like he took a full breath
maybe this guy who's so passionate about
pizza understands he's like
they might be in the backyard they might
be in the attic they might be far i need
these people to know that i'm here
it's so dedicated to it this guy's a
legend
you read it exactly they've got some mr
pibb in the bag so that's
these are people that respect pizza and
sodi
because you don't order mr pibb unless
you're deep in it
what is that it's a off brown dr pepper
oh
she's laughing at this
i want more i want i want more i want a
reality show that follows this guy
delivering pizzas
oh my god pick that up
the screaming pizza man tonight on tlc
tlc is on fire yeah
oh my god tlc is on fire because we've
been making all these videos about tlc
and how insane they are
but i've never actually put on the
network and watched i'm like well
this is all amazing stuff why am i not
watching tlc
we started recording the channel yeah i
started i started saving on dvr all the
programs
been watching 90 day fiance holy
shits this is the best show on i swear
to god this is the most entertaining
show on television
um these guys will make a show about
any goddamn thing they have like five
shows about little people
and giant people and giant people
and everyone in between um
i have this whole segment but first i
wanted to show this tai lopez
is using me in a [ __ ] ad you believe
this guy remember we made that video
with tai lopez
yeah here h3 here in my garage with tai
lopez
it's an ad what the [ __ ] ty
this is all the meme layers i knew he
was good
i knew he had it all started from his
ads and now you're in his app what the
hell
i don't think he's allowed to use our
footage like that is he
i don't know i i saw this this morning
and i tweeted i dm'd him on twitter i
was like ty what the hell dude
with the crying laughing emoji really
because
soften the blow a little yeah soften the
blow but give me a [ __ ] break doug
what is this [ __ ] did you reply
i don't know i don't know oh [ __ ] yeah
and what the [ __ ] ty now you're using me
to sell your [ __ ]
i'm not i'm not even getting paid not
endorsing your message
when we first saw his commercials on
youtube like two years ago
if someone told you this
would you believe it not for a second
either
i guess there is some kind of beautiful
poetry to to
you know acknowledging this
that i'm sitting in a lamborghini in a
tai lopez ad is pretty amazing yeah
that is pretty amazing jesus ty what are
you thinking doing this
we got to get him on the phone or
something
so anyway i just wanted to point out
that beautiful little thing that
happened
but i've got clips from 90 day fiance
okay so this show
first of all i got to tell you guys this
show every episode is two hours
long we just found out yesterday like
this [ __ ] is so consumable we
sat in bed the first episode we watched
and we didn't even notice
we thought it was 30 minutes it was just
all of a sudden it was like 1 30 am and
we're like whoa
how did that happen but yesterday we
were watching an episode
yeah and it's been forever and danny is
like how long is this it feels like
we've been sitting here for a while
and i was like i don't know 40 minutes
or something and we look and it's two
hours i've been already watching for an
hour and a half
and we thought we were watching a 30
minute show and didn't even notice
two hour episodes dude tlc is like las
vegas like
they hold you there you know in vegas
they like don't have lights or windows
they like hold you hostage there and
kind of like
hide the fact that you've been hostage
on their network for two hours and even
the commercials are interesting because
they show all their other weird shows
that they have until
there's lots of navaj yeah oh yeah i
like self-promotion little people
giant people you're just laughing at all
this so you don't
we didn't even skip the commercials we
really watched the whole two hours
right but um so 90 day fiance this show
the whole premise is so insane and i and
i
and i stress that i don't even know how
it's legal
because first it usually starts with
them overseas
well they have attorneys so it is legal
whatever it is i don't know
yeah they probably have some select
attorneys making sure that they're not
getting deported
but it starts overseas usually and then
they're bringing them over on some kind
of visa
and they have 90 days to decide if they
want to get married
because they have to decide the visa
expires in 90 days right so they have to
decide am i going to marry you
and immigrate or do i not like you
and i'm leaving and the people
well first of all the people that would
subject themselves to this are already
[ __ ] in the head right it's really
weird i don't know
they're apparently somehow in love they
met somehow that's how you usually start
i mean like who
no i mean first of all who would invite
tlc cameras
into the relationship during this
difficult time it's insane okay first of
all
second of all the way they select
couples is like incredible because
they'll
only they will specifically find
the people that and you look at them and
you say
there is no way that person cares about
the other person yeah because like my
favorite couple is this guy david and
annie
this guy david is a 45 year old he's
overweight
he's broke he has no prospect no
prospects in life
and the girl is like 20 24 right 24.
something like that and like and this is
the recurring message there's no
way that this other person cares so it's
like it's
so it's so
scant it's like so juicy
i am only now realizing that i love
reality television because
at first you react and you're like oh
this is garbage who watches this [ __ ]
but when you put on tlc all of a sudden
you're like
this i cannot turn off
i don't know last night yeah
last night the episode that we watched
which we're gonna show some clips of
it got really depressing i don't know
that i can keep watching it it's amazing
i wasn't depressed i loved every goddamn
second of it
i was getting like actually nervous for
them and
you guys gotta see this well for me i
was like [ __ ] you thought you got
marriage problems
tried dating david
thai massage this blew me out of my
chair
i said when i saw this i turned to
illinois says every
moment of my life however difficult has
been
has been worth it to watch this one
moment on tlc
i've lived the full life i said after i
saw this one clip
and i was watching this live in the
middle of a two-hour episode i was blown
away
so this guy david and this is his thai
fiance they're moving he's so
broke he can't even afford to
get his own place so they're mooching
off his best friend and staying in their
house so in this clip his best friend is
like well what are you gonna do for me
that you guys are staying at our house
and i'm telling you guys
wow i love this i have to leave my
country i have to
leave my family for i go to american
studying life with nothing no money no
job
but i believe in david make mistake i
believe in him
so beautiful i love this
tonight we're having drinks with chris
and nikki before they head back to
america
[Music]
when annie and i get to america we will
be living with chris and nikki it
makes sense because i don't have a car i
don't have an apartment i don't have a
house i don't even have a u.s bank
account
or whatever
[Laughter]
why does he specify u.s bank account
because he lives in thailand oh okay
at least he's uh charming young and
handsome
[Laughter]
[Music]
you still have our uh house ready for
you
are you excited about and scary
yeah because it's very far from from my
country
and very different everything's too
different different people
chris invited david and annie to come
live with us let's be clear this was not
my
idea at all and i tend to get excited
uh and do things without uh
telling assaulting consulting so uh
did you have some uh rules that you
wanted to talk about the only thing that
i don't
uh i don't care like that our house is
your house
right you have the downstairs we'll
share the kitchen
yeah your own bathroom you get your own
little space kitchen you're welcome
until you get back um you know back on
your feet
you know yes we get situated there and
obviously i mean even as we've talked
about i mean it's a short-term thing we
have 90 days
you're you're family to us yeah he's
implying that he's going to be here the
whole time
this guy is so he's the most pathetic
person i've ever seen and i'm not
i don't show the clip where but he's so
broke
and he's begging and mooching from
everyone and everyone's like dude just
get a job
do anything and he's like it's just not
that easy
crazy days we can get through 90 days
this is the best because uh just
we got just a little bit you know when
you're
on your 90-day visa you're not allowed
to work
but we would like you to you know maybe
volunteer to do some things like
you know volunteer to i know i like thai
food i would love
uh you you love to cook yeah sure i
could go for you
okay it's a little tight i love how he's
like we'd like you to volunteer
yeah to cook for us he's asking her to
be a maid
which is fine it's not i mean it's a
little strange the way he puts it
yeah but guys buckle up
i like uh to get massages i like thai
massage so
is that something that you would be cool
to you know
volunteer to give me a massage or
something by the pool or
a massage by the pool
holy [ __ ] this thing is when i
just i'm still i was hooked this was
when i was hooked my left this is when i
gave up
really i can't i got i'm so worried for
her this guy's such a creep
but he says it in front of his wife who
by the way has like a
trillion mile stare right now like look
how dead in the face she looks
in front of his best friend and his wife
can i get a thai massage by the way can
you volunteer
for a massage i don't i love where he's
like what is this
charity can you volunteer
what just i mean how do you wrap your
head around that
the guy's like creep i love how he's
like your thai
so thai food and thai massage
and a happy ending right happy ending by
the pool
that's how you do it in thailand right
yeah
look at his wife she is so checked out
man
oh so here it goes on by the pool or
oh he doesn't say anything
he's like yeah baby come on everyone's
just looking at each other well i mean
like i said i'm not making you do
anything i'm just saying it would be
nice
[Music]
it goes on because i cut it short and i
saw the whole episode he goes uh
she actually said no thank god yeah she
said no but
uh but i would be worried his friend was
like oh well he told me that you give
good massages that's why i asked
like he his what's his [ __ ] name
david david put her put his friend up to
asking her
that's crazy
[Music]
is that good [ __ ] or what two hours two
hours two hours
holy [ __ ] man do you do you have any
skepticism that it's real
cause like okay dan i will i ask myself
all the time
yeah let me tell you this here right now
i just don't accept that these people
are good enough actors to pull it off
have you worked like just doing sketch
doing sketches for a v
it's very even a normal person that's
and that's been around performers in
front of the camera
it's very easy to tell when someone's
acting yeah i
don't think that these these are not
even like
also they actually they followed them
for months like yeah
like uh on facebook that couple that we
made a video about
you can still they're on youtube they
have a youtube channel i think if
anything the producers probably
you know instigate yeah they manipulate
and manipulate
situations but um this is real as a
heart attack dude
this is real as a bowl of spicy curry my
dog it gave me a heart attack
this is real as a happy ending
can you imagine when he started saying
we would like you to volunteer
i thought maybe they have a charity that
he wants her to
come vulnerable
um he could just say maybe
it'd be nice if you could just help her
on the house
that's reasonable that would have been
pretty normal he's like listen
uh but he had to make it like all about
like so your thai cook thai food and uh
give me a [ __ ] hand job every once in
a while
so amazing you guys um
[Music]
here's another one so this is like half
months later
i guess his friend is kicking him out of
the house
because he's been freeloading there for
so [ __ ] long
actually let me show the wedding dress
one first i told this guy
such a catch so here they are
shopping for a wedding dress okay they
they moved to the us they're there
living with this friend please for love
i've
i've picked out of 20 hours
this is a two hour episode these
wonderful moments for us all to share
together okay
hello you're on speakerphone and
speakerphone yeah i'm good
i find the dress i really like it
really oh yeah let me ask you i i can't
wait to see it but let me ask you
one of the most important questions how
much
how much
this is uh so you expect she's gonna say
like two thousand
three thousand right like and obviously
you know
things are tight you can't afford that
man right so
318. we tag with everything
300 for a wedding dress
with our budget what do you expect her
to wear it's so
cheap for a wedding hundred dollars of
course it's as cheap as you can find
like i love it it doesn't come any
cheaper i love that
she's like okay how much 300
you cannot dress yourself for less money
for a wedding and
that pause baby you know our budget's
twenty dollars
it's amazing baby i told you go to the
thrift store go to the dollar store she
calls them from the thrift store
i found one i like it's 50 bucks baby
come on you're killing me
amazing but it gets better it gets
better
i really want to just think about it i
mean i
[Music]
good
i mean we'll just make it work somehow
so anyway let me fast forward okay
when they're buying it so i don't know
what to run it as see
let's try it
watch this [ __ ] so they go to buy this
300 dress right
that's way out of their budget
[Music]
yep it's a foreign card and we can't
reject them
and then the friend has to pay for it
what do you do she's probably so sick of
paying for their [ __ ] but what do you do
okay we'll try this all right thank you
hmm this show gives me
a card because that's so david i mean
this is
you cannot have a more awkward really
gonna get our money back i'll
get up with david you will not get a
penny back i guarantee it
there we go thank you so much okay
i'm so embarrassed and cannot pay for
the dress
man let's show us something dude oh yeah
yeah
how was that how did you guys feel you
feel that out there
it's pretty yikes it's pretty yikes guys
by the way give us a ring anytime oh we
have calls anything interesting here
uh pizza guy
well these i guess is old news stuff 808
hot meme give us a ring
um what else
okay so finally guys and i don't want to
stay on this for too long because we do
have many other things to talk about
but he later on visits with his sister
after being on the verge of being kicked
out
and he oh it's so amazing you guys
so much for doing this i really
appreciate it i hope you like it
i haven't been here in 13 years actually
it's been a long time
does she look like him with a wig
they're able to come in they are like
identical i wanted to be there i really
did
kids couldn't miss school i understood
that so you've been here for a few
months now
yeah how do you like being here so
stuff's hard they're complaining
on top of that now i have to pay rent
for the firehouse which i was
not expecting a thousand dollars a month
how are you paying all this off i am
nance
i ask myself this every day i'm
tremendously worried for both of you
what's the solution dude
there's nothing saved he's got an idea
what are you gonna do well
so that's maybe where i can ask you
oh no jesus
i came all the way down here for you to
ask me for money you hear that
this is painful wherever you are in life
whatever's going on man
feel good you are whatever is going on
you've got to be in a better position
than this guy that's true
that's true [ __ ]
i love them so there you go 90 so
tlc is in summary the greatest place for
entertainment on television today
they have the most creative and
adventure
i'd like to know i'd like to be a fly on
the wall during the tlc executive
like office who green lights and red
lights shows you know what i mean
because they have the weirdest [ __ ] all
their shows are about dwarfs
or giants i don't know what could be
too weird for them nothing's too weird
but like i wonder what it is he's red
lighting
you know what i mean that's a good
question i really liked reality i want
to know
i want a reality show about the tlc
executive who green lights
shows you know
um
the tlc executive
today starring the tlc executive
women who are attracted to horses i
married a mayor tonight
little people grave diggers it's about
people that make
little people coffins not that weird
they gotta be in love with the cops i
don't know how to pitch something to her
in love with the coffin people little
people that like having
sex in little people coffins
big wife little man it's about women
that are over seven feet tall with
men under five feet tall pretty close
and they use their head as a dildo
they got a show called my giant wife my
giant wife dude
tlc is you need to be watching tlc all
day
of the week by the way this is just for
my i love watching
this picture of shaq and his girlfriend
they can make it they could be in a tlc
show together that looks photoshopped
i said it for real i mean i think it's
real dude look up for i was i know i
mean
i've seen shaq in person he's enormous
so like it makes sense but
it's so absurd it looks funny i know i
know i looked at so many i don't think
it's photoshop i really didn't want to
get got in this
but if i was a tlc executive i'd
greenlight this show
i mean i you know what i'm thinking
right
how is he alive i mean his dick is
probably the size of her whole [ __ ]
leg
i mean how does how do they have sex i
mean just i mean frankly speaking
his foot is the size of her whole body
look at it look at the size of his face
i think it is
real it's real that's what i'm thinking
i did my due diligence
his foot his foot is the size of her
whole body
she gives birth every time they have sex
what his dick is like that big compared
to her body
right i mean she's the size of his pants
no more giving birth joe look at the
size of his pants she's the size of his
pants
of his shorts i can't get enough of this
photo man
can you um show underneath there is
another window oh you should got another
vantage point of it
yeah look at these guys i mean that
looks real
i'm telling you scale's about the same
yeah yeah
she doesn't even have to like
all right am i getting too graphic maybe
here here's a good this one's
photoshopped i think this is so
confusing because my
oh i can't turn your screen off all
right well
when we come back um we got a lot to
talk about
we've got kanye west is in uganda we've
got
uh the shane finale to talk about we've
got questions
from our fans who we love and so much
more
here in the gazebo zone do not go away
listen what's left to say about this
vibrating tube
okay now when i say vibrating tube
obviously i'm downplaying the
significance that this is one of the
greatest human advancements
in the last two to three thousand years
yes more advanced than fire or anything
nasa has ever achieved
this is the quip electric toothbrush
this toothbrush is everything i've ever
wanted in toothbrush first of all
it vibrates superior brush second of all
it tells you
when to switch quadrants so it you know
how to get that perfect two-minute brush
that dentists recommend
third the bristles are soft and heavenly
you don't have to be paranoid these are
going to damage your gums or teeth
it's strong but soft and supple and best
of all my dudes quip
electric toothbrush starts at 25
freaking dollars a comparable toothbrush
or electric fish how much is that gonna
run you two
300 bucks and it's like a huge brick
it's like a hole it's like a car battery
give me a break throw that [ __ ] out it's
time to get equip electric toothbrush
and improve your game guys that's what's
up also they send you refill packs
this thing pops off the top you put that
on you're good to go it's quick electric
toothbrush
okay get your first refill pack for 20
quip starts at 25
go to get equipped dot com slash h3
right now you get your first refill pack
free with equip electric toothbrush guys
your first refill pack is free go to
g-e-t
q-u-i-p dot com slash h3 my doggies
god bless stitch fix is an online
personal styling service that finds and
delivers clothes shoes accessories that
fit your body budget and lifestyle
just go to stitchfix.com h3 tell them
your size
what styles you like and how much you
want to spend on each item
you'll be paired with your very own
personal stylist
you will hand pick items to send right
to your door
then you try them on pay only for what
you love and return
the rest for pizza's sake shipping
exchanges and returns
are always free there's no subscription
required
you can sign up to receive schedule
shipments or get your fix whenever you
want
the styling fee is only 20 bucks which
is applied towards
anything you keep from your shipment so
basically
it's free if you keep something guys get
started now at stitchfix.com
h3 and you'll get an extra 25 off when
you keep
all the items in your box that's
stitchfix.com
h3 to get started today stitchvix.com
select h3 dollar shave clubs got it all
to look and feel and smell your very
gosh darn best in fact
i love and you're going to love you
don't have to go to the dang
store and shop for racers are so
expensive at the store
you and you have to go to the store and
talk to some 12 year old about what
rate you have to have a 12 year old come
unlock a case they keep razors behind
cases
no more dollar shave club says no more
okay they deliver everything you need
right to your door
they keep me fully stocked on what i
want and you don't run out that's the
beauty of it
they got everything okay for your hair
your skin your face
you name it they've got it and they got
a new program where they automatically
keep you stocked up on the products that
you use you determine what you want and
when you want it and it shows up right
at your door for once a month to every
six months
baby they got you covered and you never
have to have another 12 year old unlock
a glass case again so you can get razors
also they've got shampoo oh
you can have them automatically send
shampoo guys they got the whole freaking
package covered
do you shampoo your pubes guys i do
because you want to keep it luxurious
and nice
um so the pube shampoo i believe they're
marketing it as
pube and hair shampoo guys it's
perfectly balanced not dry not greasy
you pube your shampoos and you're
[ __ ] good to go my dudes
it's uh plus you get their handsome
discount the more you buy the more you
save so guys right now you can shampoo
your pubes today they've got a bunch of
starter sets you can try
for just five bucks like the shower
starter set which includes the shampoo
after that the restock box ships regular
sized products at a regular price so
what are you waiting for
get your starter set for just five
dollars today at dollarshaveclub.comh3
that's
dollarshaveclub.com h3 get shampooing
your pubes today my dudes
welcome back to the gazebo zone my good
friends
thanks for coming um you know i talked
about lacroix
in a previous episode and uh how the
chemicals
in it were safe for consumption
but um the truth is
that uh i don't know how to set this up
i got this bit planned because i've been
working on my alex jones
impression but it felt really corny let
me just do this okay
i got alex jones bit i've been working
on an impression and we got this funny
little thing
so i'm just going to do it okay
so here's ethan jones go ahead ian
so here we got this green screen and ian
is going to hold that right up there
now last week ethan
klein a liberal jew out and spent too
much time in los angeles
talking about lacroix beverages now
there is a chemical in la croix
okay now bear with me here
that when you drink turns the freaking
frogs gay
okay now you could believe ethan climbed
the liberal who says
lacroix why does it sound like final
fantasy music
is this really the song we picked
the one it's some final fantasy boss
fight
[ __ ] now now
now there's a chemical in lacroix okay
that
when you drink it okay and these
liberals out here in california
they're they've been sipping the the
blood of babies for too long okay
and they've got this interdimensional
kind of beings that are zapping their
brains and tell them that lacroix is
okay but let me tell you the truth and
bear with me here okay
there is a chemical in lacroix that when
you drink
your testosterone levels get so low that
your penis actually gets sucked up
and pokes out of your butthole okay now
the liberals want to take away your
masculinity
they want your dick poking backward out
of your butthole
because they're cucks they're liberals
okay they're trying to demasculate you
but you're a man
that's why you take infowars supplement
okay
and it may make you bleed from your eyes
but at least it gives you a rock hard
[ __ ]
okay so if you ask me if you ask me
how's my impression falling apart it's
pretty good
now if you ask me alex jones it's a
little it changes
i don't know why i had it so down if you
ask me ethan jones
there's a chemical in this beverage that
will take make your dick poke right out
of your [ __ ]
okay and so if you want to know
how to get a rock car erection how you
doing back there how long can you even
hold it
you doing good ian why don't you poke
your head out and say hi to us
you doing okay thank you man hey god
bless you
now if you want a rock hard [ __ ] put the
lacroix down
okay you little soy boy put down the soy
substitute and take info wars
black rhino it's a supplement we got it
from china we have ground up black rhino
husks
you take you shoot that in your veins it
is free based
via an injection and let me tell you the
last time i injected this i had to go to
the hospital to
they had to deflate the blood red on my
dick
i [ __ ] for 20 hours it's [ __ ]
awesome
i did believe for my eyes that is a
minor side effect
so that's about it
guys we're flying by the thank you anne
we're done we're finished
we're flying by the the what's this
phrase pant seat on our pants
seat of your pants yes what does that
mean
i don't know what do you think about
ethan jones
i like the special effects yeah we're
very
the real life effect reminiscent of the
original star wars very practical
practical effect very practical
um i hope everyone had really enjoyed
that now let me tell you about ethan
klein okay
this liberal jew has openly admitted
to vo i don't really like that this
music is good
this liberal jew has openly admitted
to voting for hillary clinton who by the
way
has eaten at least 10 babies in the
basement of a pizza joint okay
that's true now if you are going to pick
up a lacroix
you might as well eat a baby because
that's what the liberals in hollywood
are doing have you seen george clooney
he's
60 years old and he looks like he's 30
years old
how does he achieve that not by jacob
mcroy
eating babies that's right
have you have you ever tried baby
foreskin ela
no well that's your problem right there
okay because if you want to look like
george clooney at the age of 60 you're
going to need to
inject baby foreskin into your gooch
that's the area between your [ __ ] and
vagina very specific
okay put down the lacroix let's turn to
the freaking frogs gay
all right i'm done is anyone watching
a few couple oh god
we're trying stuff you know you might
not think it's funny
but it's under the gazebo so we're free
of criticism here today
okay
kanye now we talk about kanye a lot on
the show because
ian specifically is a super fan he's
obsessed with kanye
and kanye's been just it's been all over
the news yeah he's been all over the
place so it's hard to pass up the
opportunity
now ian pointed all these things out to
me
and ian you're gonna have to help me
supplement the information that we have
here
uh now what's the background on this
journal entry ian
uh he showed this to the president of
uganda
uh last week this is his to-do list
so he's in uganda recording an album
right that's the best that's right that
is correct
um so on his to this is just his to-do
list for the 15th
now on this is included um
transform zoos
that's something you'd like to
accomplish that out between three and
four thousand
and we knocked out transform zoos real
quick
start wave runner sport
make electric drone
this is his list for the week i love
transform zoo
it's just like that was so
15th i'm on the 16th baby zeus are
different now
um what do you think about this list ian
do you think this is an accomplishable
list or is he bitten off
more than he can chew well actually it
says day
15 102 i think
which is the amount of days he's been
alive i think
what the [ __ ] is this guy on wait 15
000 no that's not that well let's divide
this well let's divide that
it doesn't sound like enough date i
don't think you crush the numbers on the
scene
15 000 divided by 365 you're looking at
nope he's right he's 41 years old hey
okay dan you put do you put
you so doubt in my mind about ian's
never doubting him when it comes to
kanye never
never questions so do you think he's
been off more than he can
that's what his calendar looks like yeah
day fifteen thousand and i mean i think
the fourth one down speak to george
lucas wife
i think very doable accomplish
accomplishment for him he'll definitely
smart that one also invite
will smith to record that's very doable
i mean
he just invites him yeah transform zoo
seems a little more complex than those
two though but what do i know i'm not
kanye west
um we've got other things he he's in
uganda
uh working on music and here he is
passing out yeezys
to poverty stricken uganda ugandans
now the funny thing i had a couple of
thoughts about this first of all
these kids don't know what yeezys are do
they
are you gone think that they [ __ ]
gotta
[Music]
is probably like a year's salary i
wonder if some guy
some dudes with machetes are going to
come club them over the head and steal
their easies
i immediately just was like just
his outfit is so funny and like it's all
balanciaga and all this like high super
expensive designer
codes and i don't know the whole thing
is too funny
i just love that uh kanye's response to
like any situation
pass out yeezys like on talk shows jimmy
kimmel came out and yeezys yeah
trump he gave a pair of yeezys uganda
yeezy's for everybody ian do you think
this is a fair
piece offering or was yeezy's not an
appropriate gift
uh he gave some to the president of
uganda too and he was like thanks for
the sneakers
so they don't they definitely don't know
what yeezys are i don't think i don't
know if the kids know right the
president probably said
thanks for the sneakers he's like why
are you giving me shoes
he's like thanks for the sneakers
you dip also those
yeezys are so white that's not going to
stay white
not in uganda yeah i don't know what
that means
i don't know they're just outside
they're outside i don't leave the house
i think in uganda they're outside more
do i need to apologize for that
is that a racist uh yes you know is it
racist for me to assume that people in
uganda are outside more
it's grassy you know there's dirt that's
my first thought
it's dirty bright white it's dirtier in
uganda
there's more dirt there is that racist
forgive me do i need to apologize i
apologize to all ugandans
it's dirt there it's dirty there right
yam
no comment
um so that was a joy to behold all these
kids
[Music]
no but seriously if there's someone in
uganda that knows the true value of
those that you can
resilies on ebay for like 500 bucks
aren't those kids are in danger right i
mean am i wrong
ian back me up here
shaking his head no he doesn't think
they have your back
ian does is uganda dirtier in general
[Laughter]
back me up ian i've never been i don't
know all right
all the pictures i'm saying it looks
quite beautiful but i'm just saying
ian is complaining you know i apologize
to all the ugandans
i apologize for my ignorance statements
it was actually my statement but you're
kind of following
me what the [ __ ] wrong with you
it's so backwards um
this one's wild he built like a whole
dome city
out in the middle of like uh well why
don't you tell me and you know i don't
know what the [ __ ] i'm talking about
uh some national park and he rented out
get some audio going with that he's
having too much fun
is there any other background you want
to share in you just kind of trailed off
on
he rented out uh he rented out this
entire lodge just for him and his people
and then he built these like
these dome things in uh
in the middle of the wilderness okay
very nice
[Music]
that's a really fun way to workshop your
music
and two you shouldn't record it because
it sounds really stupid because he's
workshopping it
you know this right here
[Music]
hit him with banana
got him with the hatchet
gave the kids some yeezys
and they say it's easy
common with machete you get that is that
is that what you heard in or do you hear
genius it's a process
it's a process right
everyone on the kanye forums listening
closely like i dare you to say [ __ ]
we know who you are now [ __ ]
some say yeezy yeezy blueberry
others say scooby-doo scoopy
all right stop ethan that was pretty
good i think you should go to uganda
dude
i don't have enough yeezys to pass out
yeah
teddy fresh they'll take anything fresh
here's some used sandals
they're all dancing and [ __ ] the same
way it's uganda
i apologize it's uganda
it's [ __ ] it's uganda
i'm just saying i'm not insulting the
country of the people those [ __ ]
probably
live on like 10 cents a day
is that insult is that is that wrong
what's the daily salary of a ugandan
daily income of a
ugand ugandan i don't think we really
need to um
here let's find out annual income is
oh my god dude
what you got monthly income for a
household a household that's a whole
family
is 280 bucks monthly
yeah for a household yikes that's what
i'm saying
it's a very poor country my sandals my
used sandals cost like 30 bucks
just like play the poop he was like move
on yeah i'm sorry
it is asking for the poopity scoop kanye
out in uganda which i will deliver to
you now
this is from team kanye daly ian are you
following team kanye daily on twitter
yeah i've got him
yeah you got him covered okay good he
runs that account
this is fire right all the animals in
the jungle are like yo
[Music]
he doesn't seem like he's kidding he's
very serious about the scuba diving and
the whoop diddy's
you know all the junk this is like
all the animals in the surrounding area
because in the middle of awareness are
like fleeing
or they're going to [ __ ] it's like
the elephants that like stampede a
village because they're pissed off
yeah they're heading for highland
do you get chills when you hear the
scene as a fan
you have chills in
[Laughter]
and you want to break the you want to
deconstruct the lyrics
yeah i've got goosebumps do you think
he's just having fun or is he really
trying to
workshop something i think he eats a bit
of both
yeah he's having a blast he's been on
the the scooty poop
train for a while now this is a
recurring theme
i'm a fan of the scoop diddy poop
no question about it um
you've heard a lot about your scooping
poop
you know kanye scoops the poop that was
insane
now he's a front wiper now we know for
sure kanye is a fan of this show because
one the purple hat and two his biggest
hit of the year
poop scoop scoop the poop
okay um
i've i'm a fan of these creepy ass
robots
and there's a lot more that came out i
want to show you guys
um this is called the matt haas robot
aka the parkour robot
boston dynamics these [ __ ]
we're going to look back in 20 years
we should have stopped them when we had
the chance
you know like oh everyone's laughing and
it's trending on youtube busting
dynamics
we should have stopped them look at this
robot
not even matt haas cut out parkour this
see ya hey
looks like a it looks like it's uh a
computer rendering
because he leaps so effortlessly
this robot is jumping up
blocks i hate it this robot is gonna
are you kidding me what chance do we
have against these parkouring robots
are you [ __ ] kidding me right now
like
stop them now
you know what i'm saying it can be used
for good you know
what good is a parkouring robot except
they chase you down
you know that's a good question actually
the next video
will show you what good oh this is the
good okay yo
elo's corrected me this is the good
you know they're just trying to make it
cute but this thing is [ __ ] deadly
he's dancing okay it's what it does over
your corpse
yeah right exactly
he's dodging bullets right now
moonwalking i don't like it lasers are
zipping back i don't like it yet that's
it
we should have stopped them when we had
the chance
four million viewers everybody loves
everyone's having a good time we should
have
intervened now
[Music]
you know what i'm saying the robot dance
it's so funny
no this was our
chance you know and terminator they sent
terminator and back in time
to stop the inevitable before it
happened
that's us now okay don't i'm afraid
someone's actually going to go do
something
i'm joking for christ's sake i'm scared
though
and we must intervene
give them yeezys
that'll chill them out um what else now
speaking of gazebos these guys
okay so a lot of comments let's let's go
back to our new video okay
our new video was about the tlc catfish
and this whole thing about gazebos and
stuff
and the host of that show was
um god what's his full name i know his
name is elliot but i don't remember it
morgan elliott morgan um i had met him
once
on the set of smosh i did a game show
with him on smosh
and i realized only about halfway
through recording because he looks super
different
like now he's got a beard like i was
there too and i met him too
but i didn't realize right it was him
but then
um yeah whatever you guys get it but
he he uh it
looked like him but i didn't believe it
was the same person yeah
and um but then you pointed it out i was
like doesn't it look like elliot
this is halfway through recording
already started the video and she's like
no way
yeah and i was like yeah you're right
there's no way but it looks so much like
him it's kind of uncanny
and then i look up the credits of the
show and sure enough it's elliot now a
lot of people are like why didn't you
mention
well i didn't want to i didn't want to
i didn't i wasn't trying to personally
attack the guy yeah i thought it was
best to not
mention him by name or even to
acknowledge it because i didn't i didn't
want to give the guy
[ __ ] i don't want to [ __ ] him up you
know just making fun of the show and
kind of the persona he was playing
yeah you know it's probably not his show
you know so it's not really like yeah
his project
yeah i hope not and i'm just i'm not
trying to go after people
personally i'm just that's not i'm just
not trying to do that
and so we were trying to think like how
do we uh
how do we address at this that we've
actually
met this guy and i thought you know what
let's just
not even mention this guy i don't i'm
not trying to [ __ ] this guy's life up
mm-hmm
but um they fired back
actually really funny video and i
appreciate them so much because this is
how you embrace the meme
super funny guy the valley folk is i
guess a
sketch comedy troop could you say could
you could you uh
describe the former source fed people oh
it's all the source fed guys okay
so the valley the valley folks so they
made a sketch
in response to the gazebos so i thought
we could enjoy it here today in honor of
them
embracing the meme shout out to elliot
morgan
god bless him
yeah did you see the h3h3 totally
roasted
tlc show here let me turn it upside down
no what
then again i haven't really done that
don't you start over again because i
talked about i haven't really watched
youtube
in like 15 years that sounds pretty good
hello i am a 14 year old girl
and i like looking at frog steve did you
see ethan make fun of elliot for doing
that really bad catfish show
yeah i did joe that's why i'm in here
i'm hiding from residual embarrassment
jokes aside dude what kind of [ __ ]
[ __ ] goes on a catfish show when i own
a company
i like ariana grande and coffee dear
google
do actions have consequences or can i
get away with it elliot
elliot what's up did you see that ethan
from h3h3 roasted your ass on national
internet
well no i didn't joe you haven't seen it
i don't know if i want to oh man okay um
get ready
i think he was probably when he saw that
i made a video about it he was probably
like like oh [ __ ] here we go
but i i didn't want him to watch it and
feel bad that was my
so i hope he didn't based on the
response
i mean they took it and uh and i think
they
definitely made the best of it i mean
the video did really good they made a
really funny video response to it
yeah so there you go and then also feel
the cold tide of professional shame wash
over your body
okay joe well here's the thing uh mean
internet comments are just
manifestations of truths i keep buried
deep within for fear of confronting them
head-on
look you don't need to act like you're a
predator you have a zip
he looks so much different yeah he's all
shaved he looks like
so young like a sweet they they styled
him to be like this sweet young
christian boy yeah they tried to dress
style him so they're like this guy could
never be considered
to be a predator he's too sweet and good
and too good of a good christian old boy
you know bearded elliot on the other
hand
definitely could never have hosted that
show i'm kidding
i'm kidding turn your arm can i mention
the most effed up part of this is that
they're having her meet him at a
gazebo
this guy is [ __ ] good it's pretty fun
what it's pretty
pretty funny yeah it was how are you
gonna respond
probably very stoically joe and uh with
a dry
sense of humor something that conveys
authenticity but is also brand
appropriate
most of all most importantly tantamount
i will
not embarrass myself
[Music]
very reminiscent of gamer guns okay so i
googled what's the best way to respond
to internet ridicule
and this is what i found oh revenge yeah
i mean i don't want to get political but
it's an option so
oh yeah guess what sometimes looks like
you kind of have a double chance maybe
work on that
got him yeah
yeah yeah anyway you guys
get it go watch the whole you guys
should go watch it it is really funny
yeah these guys are great
very charming very uh very very good
very nice
the valley folk so shout out to these
super troopers out there
may i may they join us under the gazebo
here today and all
hold hands delightfully under the gazebo
so shout out to all those guys
very very sweet um
no elliott's sweetheart i mean i only
met him that one time
very sweet very nice guy very happy to
share the stage with the guy
um and uh i wish him all the very very
best
and uh i do i have some questions for
him i wouldn't maybe we should have him
a call because one i'm curious was that
his clothes or did they make him wear
that
shirt with the zipper on it two i'm
wondering how much was staged
i'm afraid to ask though because i i
don't i'm afraid to find out it was all
fake i don't i almost don't want to know
that
i don't know if you can't even tell you
that's serious and there's probably an
nda
tlc doesn't [ __ ] around
um maybe but again this goes back to the
thing i don't think that that
little girl in those parents can be that
good of actors to
convincingly act that you know what i
mean
well the parents were okay
i think that the girl would convince me
that it's real
if she was acting she's got a bright
future you know
yeah but then that's also what i wonder
is like
if they're that good and they're trying
to be actors
why don't we see these people in other
pla things
you don't yeah conclusion
tlc is real
shout out to uh the valley folk out
there god bless
uh here's a great one
how's everyone doing today let me check
the calls anyone here
grandmother passed away wanted to thank
you
thank you i mean hey thanks that's the
note
appreciate uh pizza guy
how do there's this just trying to
figure out how to do these calls
he's an air force high ranking officer
we've got a general on the line wanted
to ask about possible future guests for
the show
okay well thanks to everyone for holding
i think that i will not take any calls
sorry um should i take this pizza guy he
says had a similar experience as the
pizza guy
how interesting can that be
not sure move on
dead air i think we need to give people
instructions of what kind of calls do
you want yeah i want them to be more
topical
you know like we were talking about the
creepy robot that has a parkour robot
ever chased you down and
murdered your family because that
happens every day
or someone who's got a question about
kanye or something you know or some
comment
like that you know to expand on the
conversation where
we're having you know um
yeah we're working on it
now do you guys want to watch
this what's this little twist here for
you
this is a great one
yeah i checked my internet i follow his
speeches
he knows what he's talking about he's
these other these other guys are
simpletons by comparison
uh
i gotta love this [ __ ] guy everyone
collapsed still like yep
this dude you mentioned being able to
play
just take a [ __ ] nap um
what it's not even on autoplay um yeah i
love that i love trump
he's good you know he's really well read
anyway hal hitler
yep he says it's so fast that you don't
even understand what you think they
didn't process
it yeah he's like listen trump's great
i've read his book
he's super intelligent i love his
politics i think he's great for the
country anyway
hitler i love you gotta end any
point you make with that from now on
anyway hal hitler
but the audience everyone in the
audience is rocking it
watch this guy in the red takes a bite
of his camera
[Applause]
dude takes a bite of a sandwich on the
hal hitler
watch this [ __ ]
[Applause]
yeah that's such a weird one i uh i'm a
huge
fan of uh of trump's platform
he's got a lot of smart things about
immigration he's bringing jobs back
you know his tariffs i think are good
for america big fan
love america god bless everyone and uh
hi hitler
love your passion love your enthusiasm
it's so anti it's so you cannot be an
american
and a nazi they are
water and oil okay
you cannot throw a heil hitler in
america you just
can't do it i don't think it works in
any country
it works in some countries but
i'm just saying that america's not out
in the public like that
that's a fair you know that's a fair
point you make a fair point
you make a fair point heil hitler you
forgot to howl hitler at the end
um read his book huge fan he's a real
intellectual
health hitler
he's you're endorsing trump not hitler
why does hitler get all this praise he's
[ __ ] gone
you know you're talking about trump
um he likes hitler he likes hitler
as well as trump
fascinating stuff um
fat oh this one is was really bad for me
fat you guys know what a fat burger is
you're like unfortunately i do
so we've had an ongoing debate about
baby wipes here on the show and i love
baby wipes i'm a huge proponent of baby
webs but unfortunately
this kind of started seeping into my
reality that
flushable is misleading
yeah extremely learned this here on
during the podcast it's been a hard
truth to swallow
um a lot of people were like hey ethan i
want you to know those aren't actually
flushable and i'm like yeah i eat
i was like suck my tiny jewish dick and
i have stopped flashing them but you
didn't
well i think that
let me give you an anecdote i mean this
morning i
went white wet and there's a lot of [ __ ]
on it
because you gotta do more dry then and
then
it seemed fine what's gonna be fine like
it seemed ready to go but it wasn't
but it seems like when you go wet it's
probably generally
you know less what's going on with this
mic god damn
it's like all over the place
um jesus when you wipe when you go wet i
have a feeling
it's nicer maybe but when i go wet
it's [ __ ] wild when
you don't want that you know what we're
gonna see but you don't want a [ __ ]
covered wet wipe of mine in the trash
can
you have your own trash can i'm telling
you you'll smell it
i don't think so we have separate
bathrooms
um
but uh so apparently there's a
phenomenon
of people flushing what wet wipes
of raw sewage flushable quote-unquote
flushable wipes and hair
turning into such a huge cluster of
of [ __ ] that it's actually clogging huge
city
main pipelines so the danger is actually
not to your home pipes
but the danger is to the city pipes
everyone
yes and the city is spending millions of
dollars
to take out these proverbial fat burgs
they're called
that i'll share with you here today but
i don't know i mean
um
um chris chris had the perfect rebuttal
to when i was like you know some people
flush the baby wipes and he said uh
there's [ __ ] on him and i was like yeah
there's [ __ ] on them why don't you just
take a [ __ ] in the trash can
well why don't you open it up and the
show people are favoring the moment here
developing i'm developing here so the
charleston water these guys have been on
a
tear lately this is the charleston water
system these guys are killing it on
twitter
verified and everything um
they've been doing psas about these
[ __ ]
fatbergs so here you go divers swim
these now that's a hero forget about a
mascot and a burrito getting punched
that's not courage that's not a hero a
hero is a diver well maybe it is but i'm
not gonna quantify courage but
divers swim through 90 feet of raw
sewage to unclog giant hairy
fatberg can you [ __ ] imagine you're
diving
through raw sewage damn i can't see
this you see that like that looks like
something from a scary movie
like an like a monster it does look like
a it kind of looks like my profile
nose mouth chin hair
so this is just [ __ ] i find it
interesting that sewage turns black
because [ __ ] is brown obviously as we
all know
kind of interesting you want to take a
bite of that would you take a bite of
that how much should take a bite of that
you can barely look at it just
on the computer it's spaghetti it's
marinated spaghetti
anyway yeah it's awful it is awful so i
stand
corrected on the issue of flushable baby
wipes and by the way
i find it pretty whack
that they can advertise it as flushable
when it's clearly
uh completely not flushable yeah like
literally not flushable how is that
legal
i mean i i find it to really be the
fault of these
manufacturers that they're able to get
away with this deceptive marketing
because when i buy flushable wipe
there's a whole market for flushable
wipes i'm assuming
that this is somehow a valid statement
you know it's crazy i can't believe it i
don't know i find that to be
some kind of false advertising um
there's there's
so much more fat burgs they're called
which is a great
lovely name um
hope you guys are hungry
look at this is the brave [ __ ] that goes
and dives in raw sewage
i wonder what those guys get paid man
that picture um move right like that's a
hole
it looks like look at this crazy [ __ ]
he's not even wearing protection his
sleeves are out
he's posing with the fatberg
his arms are exposed his face is exposed
that's courage
it's pretty dude that guy is
so yeah this is like a crazy operation
man
look at it look at all the work they do
they says do you use flushable wipes in
your home turns out they're not so
flushable after all
in fact they just caused a major
city-wide uh water pump clog
in charleston charleston water says it's
becoming a huge issue for them too we
break it down
tonight oh wow there's a whole
investigation going on
so what are you going to do about it i
think i'm going to get some
bidets i think i'm going to get bidets
installed i really like these totos
these are these crazy ones we tried it
when we were in montreal
but i had diarrhea so my i don't know if
i talked about this i had like really
crazy diarrhea
and so my [ __ ] was super sore from
wiping so vigorously
and so when i shot the water my [ __ ]
would hurt because i had like open
wounds
so i didn't get to enjoy it that much
and then when i
because it's like a communal uh toilet
it has a fan
setting so it's um oh it has a dryer
first of all it has a fan so when you
sit on it it sucks in the air
it sucks the [ __ ] smell out of the air
what
i swear to i swear to you right now and
but the weird thing is
so it sprays your [ __ ] and then
the problem that i had with it frankly
speaking because everyone talks about
these bidets like they're
you know heaven sent and this is a this
is what i feared what happened but water
dripped down my balls
shitty water was dripping down my balls
for for [ __ ] sake
hmm probably need to learn how to use it
you know
how do i avoid water shooting down my
balls gonna take some
learning okay i'm willing to learn but
the weird one for me
because this is in a hotel so this has
had a lot of people [ __ ] in it
um the seat was warm love that the seat
comes up when you approach it love that
but then they have a dryer setting
because they know that your balls are
all wet and your [ __ ] and
everything's all wet
and then the dryer smelled like it was
blowing shitty air in my face
that sounds gross and like not why did
you have your face in the toilet bowl
i didn't damn it smelled like
i needed a i needed some fresh squirt
water on my face
um just a little pick me up but the so
it wasn't like
my [ __ ] smell though it was like the
[ __ ] smell of like
thousands before me oh yeah it's in the
hotel
so it's blowing like shitty air like
fatberg air
gross yeah so that i had a problem with
but but i think i'm gonna go the bidet
route i feel like we are responsible
probably for telling a lot of people to
use baby wipes
bro with the amount of baby wipes i
flush i'm personally responsible for
destroying the septic scissors
of all of israel and los angeles and new
york
so i literally take it back and say that
i do not
use them anymore removing the
endorsement of flushable
so-called flushable baby wipes yeah
and um i'm gonna i think i'm gonna go
the bidet rope the toe toes
gotta try it i mean even
the thing i always i love this thought
the king of
england how did he wipe his ass you know
what i'm saying
like back in the day when the king was
like god
and he's got like literally gold woven
dresses that he like lifts up and shits
does someone wipe his ass you know what
i mean no i don't think so you think
that
king gods gods what do you think the
queen does
of england well
no she's more modern she's more modern
she has a toto
no but i'm talk this is pre-toto this is
pre-modernity
this is god's spokesman this is the cl
this is god basically the king of
england
you think he wipes his own ass we're all
human
after all not king george
i bet you he had peasants like i bet you
he laid on his back and some
servant [ __ ] cleaned his [ __ ] off
i don't think so
i bet you there's a history historian
who knows
hold on hold on hold on i'm going to
[ __ ] google searches did king
george wipe his own just drop the link
it's got a nice little illustration in
there too although i'm not
talking specifically about the king of
england here why did medieval kings have
servants to wipe their butt for them
couldn't they just do it themselves
why does this guy act like he knows
her top answer is what makes you think
they dig can you give me a source on
this i've never heard of it
oh man
this is the this is the kind of history
that we need to learn about
dan what did you draw me here at all
times had it now see
oh god this illustration is hilarious
that was mostly what i said
is this safe to show it's a drawing
yeah i guess so look at this [ __ ]
but this is not the king of england do
you understand
look at her that's a fine upperclass
woman though
that's is she peeing in a bowl i think
so yeah that's how you did it god
it's come a long way i love how on one
hand they're like
so over the top with how they dress and
behave and then on the other hand
she's peeing in a bowl you know what i
mean
i have a feeling the king george of of
england
at the height of his power didn't wipe
his own ass
sorry mediaville can't okay here you go
there's actually uh
um i'm i'm reading uh this is important
guys bear with me
all right i'm closing this i'm out
somebody back there see if you can find
an answer to that because this is
important
shane the shane jake paul series
has come to a finale it's finally over
it's finally over the final episode was
posted at almost two
hours long
oh my god
it was two hours long there's two
moments that i really want to share with
you guys they're short they're sweet i'm
not gonna get into the whole thing
but i guarantee you're gonna love this
so um let's pull this clip up so this
one
alyssa violet who's jake paul's
ex-girlfriend
she slept with logan paul um
and she begged him please we made a
mistake don't tell
anybody that we slept together logan's
response
was the best
let's hear it we just went to a club
like we normally would do
and just hung out and then drank and it
was just
a bad decision on both of our parts
we texted after and we were like i was
like
please don't ever like tell jake i don't
ever want this to get out like it was so
stupid
he was like listen like i'm savage
maverick
oh [ __ ]
that's all i love that she's like please
don't tell anyone he said listen i'm a
savage i'm a maverick
and then he made like a whole diss track
about it and stuff she was in it by the
way so i don't know what
yeah i really don't know what's what
with this [ __ ]
i i tell you what the new
the new video has over 10 million views
and it's two
effin hours long my god nuts
somehow he tricked people in the wat
like it used to be everyone was like i'm
so sick of jake paul
right and somehow shane has found a way
to trick people
into watching 150 million
views into jake paul it's brilliant um
so there you go
i'm a maverick and then second of all
this one of greg
paul trying to crowd surf
greg paul is the biggest [ __ ] douche
on the planet that's what i've
determined if anything from this
dude just don't do it you're a
god and these are kids like you're being
carried by kids man they can't bear the
load watch this
he slowly sinks in there conduct 12 year
old my dude
don't jump on kids
the way he just sleeps but i'm a kid
i gotta watch that again it's like dude
don't just say
you know what not for me i'm 50 years
old
just so young in a spirit yeah he's got
a tight eyeshadow age
is nothing but a number yeah comes
florida kelly said
come on baby aj ain't nothing but a
number didn't r kelly write that for
like his 15 year old girlfriend
oh yeah yeah that's love
damn that's crazy or kelly [ __ ]
that's crazy yep people used to get away
with [ __ ] they don't get away with now
like can you imagine apparently having a
cult
so people do get away with stuff still
but can you imagine a pop star being
like agent nothing but a number baby
to his 15 year old girlfriend
it's kind of what greg paul does
allegedly allegedly
you know what i'm going to hit you with
the slow motion because i want to see
this play-by-play
i gotta savor this moment this is the
end of the documentary guys this is the
best part
the guy thinks he's like a rock star man
there's a bunch of 12 year olds trying
to carry your fat ass
see yeah like a bag of dirt
there's some poor kids under him getting
squashed
that's that is nightmarish by the way
let me turn down the music
[Music]
yeah but bill anyway
um so out of the two-hour documentary
that is pretty much
[ __ ] it's like eight hours total
something like that seven hours
guys if you have questions comments
suggestions videos something you want to
talk about
or watch email us at podcast
h3h3productions.com today
our first question comes from
nada hey there
on a podcast not that long ago you
mentioned when your old video shake that
dick and quickly shove the topic away
and embarrassment you've even removed
the video from the channel
which further perpetuates the idea that
you are ashamed but i believe that it
was one of the funniest things you've
ever made
so i think you should react to it and
tell us how you came about making it
and how you convinced eight people to
cheer you on as you shook your dick for
youtube have a blessed day well you
haven't thank you for that
yeah it's embarrassing i mean it's like
my dick
like you see my dick it's like the whole
outline it's everything it's very
embarrassing
i feel like maybe it's a good suggestion
maybe we should make a video
yeah if any like an h3 video because
that is the one video that my dad
started there's a good story behind it i
got this zoned yeah
i got disowned for that video that was
the last video i shared on my facebook
page this the lore behind that video is
pretty good
i think if anything we can make a good
h3 video yeah but like is it
am i is it appropriate can we show that
footage
because it's like the outline of my dick
underpants
yeah you think that's fine i mean you
don't actually see
no you don't see my dick yeah if
you know because you can see like
titties under like you could see like
a tit outline under a shirt and that's
fine
that was the whole joke right where's
the dick you get the titties you get the
ass
where's the dick
i'll think about it nada but um how did
we convince those people on the street
that those were real people sitting on
the street and we were just like
hey do you guys mind getting a little
like
excited for us for the video i think
he's talking about the party at the end
oh i thought it stopped the old dude
best actor ever we'll save it we'll talk
about it
i think there's enough lore behind that
to make it interesting
this one comes from marv hey guys so
those people were my friends
they were well aware with our antics by
then
um marv hey guys i'm ashamed to admit it
but i'm one of those people that
eat boogers it's been a habit of mine
for as long as i can think i'll eat
boogers probably once or twice a day
less if i'm a lot of people and more if
i'm alone and bored
i got good at hiding it from people he's
like an alcoholic
i hide my alcohol around the house i
wonder if he
i wonder if he'll put a booger under the
table and then when people leave he
takes it off and eats
just don't give him ideas why i'm trying
to help the guy with the hobby
i got good at hiding it from people even
for my girlfriend of five years
jesus as she never knew as far as i know
even though i know it is disgusting i
don't feel disgusted
it's weird and i'm more uh i'm more
disgusted with myself that i keep doing
it it's an
urge that is hard to suppress but i feel
like at least i do
it less than i used to i try to use
other methods of disposing of boogers if
they are available and convenient
but i'm a bit more it sounds like dude
this is intense
um i'm a bit more hesitant to do it if i
know
i breathe through some weird chemicals
or dust with my nose
since i believe boogers are there to
catch particles to prevent it from
getting in your lungs
but sometimes i'll still even do it then
there's not much of a taste to a booger
if i'm being honest or at least not that
i can describe
there are different textures though
mainly how hard and soft they are
and some are more juicy
you're probably sick and disgusted now
but as i am there you go there's not
much more to it
thank you keep it up proud of you marv
well first of all mar i applaud you for
your brave your bravery and your honesty
and sharing this anecdote because it's
important to know that they are
out there and it's important and it's
nice to get in your mind and
kind of see i love some of the little
details of like
sometimes if i'm around chemicals i'll
not eat my boogers but sometimes
i'll still eat them you know
or like i'll hide it from my girlfriend
but i [ __ ] eat buggers
that's gnarly dude well actually um
i'm not gonna shame my booger eating you
know
friends and family members out there or
whoever
you know i smell i'll fart on my hand
and smell it
so you have never do it
you have never farted on your hand and
smelled it you always say it as a joke
do you actually do it
i have done it i mean i don't it's not
something i regularly do but i've done
it
okay do you have not farted on your hand
and smelled it all right
has anyone backed their fart on their
hand and smelled it no
dan shut up don't [ __ ] say it like
that because it's because it smells dank
bro
and i know you farted on your hand and
smell it and we'll never he ran to the
bathroom
of course he's doing it right now zach
moses of course thank you zach the one
honest guy
of course how can you not thank you zack
your honesty
you're fresh of breath [ __ ] i don't
believe that
chico have you farted on your hand and
smelled it he's
he's on a call okay
you don't believe zach why would not lie
about that
i don't know doc are you being truthful
i i swear to god i believe him this is a
phenomenon
i don't believe you frankly i didn't i
don't i don't get
why would you need to do it that's the
what's the motivation yeah because you
want but you're gonna sell it anyway no
it's right it's stronger
it's a stronger smoke i don't factor in
it too
i haven't done it in a while but to sit
here and tell me you've never
butter cupped yourself yeah [ __ ]
outrage in a lie
you fart and you buttercup it never done
it
i don't buy it and what else have you
lied to me about
um about this guy who eats his boogers
incidentally uh serendipitously i saw
this article
that eating buggers may boost immunity
so there is a biological explanation for
all you
people who are shoveling boogers into
your mouth eating burgers may boost
immunity
scientists suspect i'm not going to
bother to read it but you get that yeah
here look at this little bugger
picker i mean all that means is that
they're full of germs and you're just
eating germs right yeah cool
exactly dan
so eat your buggers it's good for you
from ben hello ethan and eel i was
listening to podcast 88 and you all
brought up the idea of enjoying the act
of smelling your own farts
i would like to weigh in on this debate
and let you know that i'm with ethan on
this one
i was against him on his wiping
technique but this is some common ground
thank you i'm glad we found some common
ground then
i like i think the liking smelling i
liking your own fart is a biological
thing because animals naturally try to
smell their own territory
so your own bodily smells will smell
better you than they would of someone
else's because it indicates it's not
their territory
i think that enjoying your farce is
totally normal and human nature
i would even go as far as to say that
most of us hot box our cars with farts
and secretly enjoy it i don't
he goes on to say you are my favorite
content creators on youtube
and papa blast thank you so
thank you ben for corroborating what
i've always said is that ela is a
liar prolific liar in fact um
is chico still on the phone yeah
kid does he can you ask him just i want
to know if he's farts on his hand and
smells it
do you think he does do you fart on your
own hand and smell it ethan wants to
know
never ever he says shaking his head
because they're lying he's a reasonable
person
give me a break i think it's a 50 50
kind of thing
i think it's a front i think it's a
should we say that's a lie should we say
do you like the smell of your own farts
or
no
you tolerate the smell of your own fart
no i still think it smells like farts
it's not see i'm willing to go as far as
to say that
that my own farts don't smell as bad to
me as they probably do to other people
i'll go that far when you fart
it bothers you the smell of your own
fart
no i'll agree with what dan said it's
not as gross so it's taller
so it's tolerable to you it's horrible
but that doesn't mean i go out of my way
to [ __ ] scoop it up
if you're sitting and watching tv and
you rip a fat one you're not gonna get
up and leave the room no
you'll bask in it but i'm not gonna
enjoy it
you're not gonna breathe deep or
anything do you hold your nose do you
avoid breathing
no you don't go out of your way to avoid
it no so you breathe it
yeah and do you not think about the
smell at all do you like think like oh
that was a [ __ ]
that was a pretty gnarly one or that one
wasn't that bad no i do think
okay so you're analyzing you're smelling
it you are smelling your own
enjoy it though all right so what are
the the options are you don't like your
own part at all
you can't tolerate it no no no let's
just say no have you ever
farted on your hand and smelled it yes
or no
that's the one all right
and your whole life i mean you know as a
kid your whole life have you ever once
in your life
now or ever before
just yes or no all right and i'm setting
it to run through the weekend so we can
get a
nice sample size well you update us now
i'm not waiting till monday
all right pulls up everybody let's go
finally from
alfredo alfredo
how could you never betray the family
hey ethan yell first of all great to see
you guys doing better recently
hope you guys keep up the great momentum
but now enough of the funny business
well i don't think that was very funny
at all this is serious [ __ ]
a year ago i being a lazy ass thick boy
chose to sit down and pee
in my toilet since then it's been my
preferred method of urination
recently i saw messi come forward and
mention that he does it as well
this gave me the courage to mention this
among my friends they all ridiculed me
and made me even question my decision
this is a guy related question i'll
leave it to us guys
sorry elo um
is it weird to pee sitting down well
again i'm not i don't want to shame my
fellow
my fellow boys here if you eat your
boogers
if you pee sitting down that's a kind of
a beautiful testament to how diverse
we as human beings really are some of us
far on their own hands and smell it
which is as i
understand it very normal and courteous
let me check on that
um i don't think it's weird at all i
know a lot of guys that pee
sitting down personally i don't like
it because i feel that i can't squeeze
out as much
liquid as when i'm standing up because a
lot of times if i'm taking a [ __ ]
what do you see he looks shocked what
the [ __ ] do you see
what do you see 55 yes
[Laughter]
it's early it's early we need more 733
votes it's not enough it's not a big
enough sample size
not a big enough sample size
no yes it is you said 700
that will change maybe it's fluctuating
really fast nah
well that will change five percent at
most from now
in either direction that's what i'm
telling you
ela oh it went down it went down
this is why i gave it three days we need
we need thousands of responses we're
dreaming in a
cloud of fart you guys are the weird one
i would never
you guys are the weird ones
when you scratch your balls do you smell
your hand oh yeah of course
no why
why why would you because it's the same
thing you want to know what's going on
there
what am i crazy how smelly are your
balls it's not
really i don't think mine really has a
scent there's nothing to smell sometimes
there's a little babaganoush smell man
or not your balls but like your region
like you're [ __ ] the region
you're especially shampoo cubes
zach do you smell your hand after you
scratch you know he does
let me guess this dude no because zach's
not a [ __ ] liar he's not
a shame to it i have no reason to lie
about it
yeah you're all lying
[Laughter]
you love your man musk that's what it is
thank you zack although man musk is not
a phrase
particularly happy to get behind but i
appreciate what you're saying
but you know like the area between like
your thighs
you know yes that that's what i'm
talking about
he loves it i love it all right
this one it's not over it's just
beginning
and you make sure that what are we at
right now what's the percentage it's 54
46. oh it's changing so much give me a
break
listen what we're doing here is
important we're destigmatizing
we are getting out in the open that we
are beautiful diverse creatures some of
us
pee sitting down some of us eat our own
boogers and some of us far in our
hands and smell it okay it can still be
gross
nope nope no it cannot be
i'm just saying we're out there and
maybe we maybe maybe it'd be nice
ela to not feel ashamed of myself all
the time
you know oh i took a piece of [ __ ] out
of the toilet and smelled it
big [ __ ] whoop zach you do that right
of course why wouldn't i i think it's
interesting that 55 percent of people
down to 53. i think people are goofing
on me
if anything you guys just be honest on
this poll
but either way you said ten percent of
so i don't give a [ __ ] what it drops
you just got cobied on this
this this sample too this is the live
audience we gotta wait for the vod
audience to roll in it's cut from a
different cloth how many people have
voted now uh
yeah you're gonna tell me that's not a
significant sample size
1700 people give me a break
you guys are walking you guys think
you're so special you don't fart on your
hand smell it
so bourgeois yes
us peasants farting on our hands and
smelling it oh look at you eela
that's right
that's right my name now
to people that don't fart on their hand
and smell it
i can't do the impression that's all
i've got here today
so i think we covered a lot of ground i
think we learned a lot
and um i want everyone to be very
comfortable and ha
let's take a call for christ i didn't
take a call today pizza guy
vape nation wants to talk about kids
vaping
do you want a boy or a girl has an
answer or
how does the king wipe his ass has an
answer
are you serious about the king taylor
you
are on the air tell me do you know about
if kings how kings wipe their ass or are
you
are you [ __ ] with me
taylor taylor is it
drop do you have to unmute or something
oh maybe he's no
[Music]
no he's live all right taylor god bless
you appreciate you you're the progress
it's worth the shot
you're the greatest that ever did it um
what else we got
is the air it he is at the air force oh
yeah [ __ ] this guy oh
these are all terminated okay screening
room i'm trying to understand this let's
talk to andrew he's a high-ranking air
force
official i don't know what he has to say
andrew are you there
no okay this is a hit guys we are
killing it today on these calls one
eight hundred
one 808 hot meme let's just get a call
uh do you want this guy has a similar
pizza experience
vape nation fan talks about kids vaping
or do you
want a boy or a girl
i don't know i'm not compelled
[Music]
um
okay just move on no no no no
let's talk with scotty scotty you're on
there
why isn't this not working i guess it's
not working yeah it sounds like
something is not working
uh harrison you are on
the air
harrison just keep going this is great
yeah i'm trying yeah know this is
amazing
compelling stuff harrison talk to me for
christ's sake
what the [ __ ] is going on
well you sure it's working i think it's
obviously not
yeah well then do you want to come look
at it
you want to just prolong this i was just
going to ask them if they fought in
their hand or not
i didn't care about anything that i just
wanted to know
about their habits in the bathroom then
i think let's just okay let's wrap this
baby up
guys i'll do all my fellow hand farting
let me tell you you know what i you know
what i like the most about people that
fart in their hands melody though it's
at 52
still you act like that's a victory for
you
i'm just saying it's going down you know
what i like about people that fart in
the hand of smelly
they are courageous and they are
truthful
i find it hard to believe that people
don't like the smell of their own farts
because it's but you're saying it like
you enjoy it i do i enjoy it
so why what's hard to believe it's a
gross smell because it's like biological
i feel like
you almost cannot deny because if you're
willing to sit there and analyze the
smell of your own fart which you've
admit to doing
in a sense you couldn't do that without
enjoying you couldn't
and you couldn't do that without
enjoying it right no you're not making
any sense
why i'm not analyzing i'm just sitting
there
and thinking like people do you think
all the time
you're thinking yourself what kind of
fart is that you could take a smell no
it's like
oh this is really gross or oh this is
not that bad
you know it's just taut i like when it's
grosser
okay like a diarrhea fart you're like
damn
that shit's foul but it's good i don't
know
what are you are you kidding i don't i'm
not kidding
i'm being real with you right now i
don't know
am i grossing you out
well i think it's gross yeah i think
i thought that was the what most people
think
that art smells but are you amazed now
that over 50
say they fart on their hand and smell it
like that's kind of an interesting
revelation right it is so there you go
we're uncovering things here on the h3
podcast we're
this is so off the rails we got to end
this yeah let's end it
all right um off the rails guys
have a blessed weekend
hope you all enjoyed here with us today
on the h3 podcast
live i thank you all so much for joining
us
i am so excited for the weekend i hope
you all have a great terrific week and i
am so excited um
anything else going on not really oh
really
so we will see oh next week we have tom
segura
and christina p two of my favorite
people
on when uh thursday wednesday
it's wednesday because i thought we were
going to disney on friday thursday
okay so they're coming on wednesday at
the usual time
and then the day after that i'm so
excited i'm taking the whole family to
disneyland
we are because for some reason all of
our
family members birthday is in the same
season it's all in the fall so we're
doing a klein family bonanza there's 10
of us going together it's going to be
freaking awesome so if you were in
disneyland are you sure it's on thursday
i thought it looked on the calendar
the end of this podcast is so off the
rail i'm just looking at my [ __ ]
calendar
no hang on guys no this is important
disneyland on the 25th oh yeah that is
thursday
so if you're in disney on thursday come
say what up we're going to be wearing
orange beanies and looking like a bunch
of
clowns and ela's going to make a shirt a
custom shirt for everyone
it says clan family birthday bonanza
2018.
can you have a picture of me farting
like a ring
cloud and then trailing my hand up to my
nose
no okay ela's gonna have a talking to me
she's gonna
prohibit me from smart smelling farts
are we off the rails dan
i think we're off the rails yeah let's
end it guys thank you all
so very much have a nice weekend
oh watch go uh ozark i keep saying
gosard
watch ozark that show's [ __ ] awesome
yeah
really good i'm gonna run home and watch
the season finale of season two
a huge fan of that show and tlc by the
way watch
my huge wife that one's the best one
[Music]
her vag is so wide that her husband swim
swims when they have sexy swims in her
vagina off the rails right
all right end it dan just end it bye
you